I think it's just been a
very interesting time, right?
I think so much has
happened in this two years.
Technology, Zooms, George
Floyd, I mean it's a lot, right?
For me as a creative, all
those things have influenced
and touched me, and I
think it's just great
that we can start to see people again
I could do this with you.
In this conversation, you're going to hear
about dressing Oscar winners,
the return of the catwalk,
and whether working from
home killed the suit.
If you've been dressing for
work from just the waist up,
you've definitely missed this.
The crowds, a touch of glamor,
dressing up and heading out.
He has dressed heads of state, royalty,
and Hollywood stars on and off screen.
He describes a suit as a coat of armor,
and believes wearing
one boosts confidence.
He is a tailor, after all.
Now he's back for London Fashion Week.
Hello, and welcome.
My guest today is the fashion designer
and Savile Row powerhouse, Ozwald Boateng.
Ozwald,
great to have you with us.
Thank you,
thank you very much.
I have to say,
the best dressed man I think
I've had in the studio.
Thank you, I'm gonna take that.
But definitely gonna absorb
that, yeah, absolutely,
thank you.
You should,
you have not let us down.
It's beautiful.
What is this?
This is--
So this is actually
a flannel, very English fabric,
but the design is based on a
fabric called the kente cloth,
which is a fabric that
is born out of Ghana,
and specifically by the tribe,
the Ashanti who you had
specifically young men who weave it,
hand-weave it.
Men weave it?
Yeah, men, exactly.
There's a whole superstition
about women weaving,
and so there's--
Ah okay, there's always
a superstition with women.
There's, exactly, so,
and the fabric is always
made for effectively chiefs,
which are effectively kings.
So in a way, it's like a, the
kente cloth's like a coat of,
your tribe, exactly.
Your tribe?
So I decided to take that
and mix that with English
tradition, flannel.
Take, and usually it's multicolored,
so I took all the colors out
and made it one solid color.
I use fashion and color as a way
to modernize the traditional
suit, and over time,
I never recognized that my culture,
my cultural roots were
influencing my choices in color.
So my color palette was very African
without realizing it was
African, 'cause it just,
the color made sense to me.
I always went for color that
had a richness and depth,
because if you have a richness
and depth in the color,
it means more people can wear it.
They will say I, I'd hear many times
that I can't wear that color
because it doesn't work,
and I'd say, well actually it's,
that's not really what it is.
Actually, it's at what shade?
There's like 1,000
different versions of blue,
and it's endless.
So it's all about the right shade,
so I developed my own
sort of color palette
or shades which meant
many people could wear,
and then it evolved from
there and then at a point,
when I recognized that my
color palette was very based
in my African heritage,
that's when I started bringing
more of my understanding
in terms of textile into my work.
London Fashion Week is back.
There's been a break,
of course, the pandemic,
and this is your first time showing in...
12 years, can you imagine?
It's been a while.
A while.
So are we seeing things
like this in the collection?
You'll see definitely
hints of this, definitely.
And this has sort of become my,
sort of like my house-designed fabrics,
so you'll definitely see that
and other variations of it, so.
So the show, can you, I
know you can't tell me
about the designs, but is there a theme?
What's the thought behind it?
So I did this huge show
in New York in 2019,
and it was, the show was,
actually was called AI,
interesting enough,
but instead of saying
artificial intelligence,
it was more about the individual,
so I flipped the letters and I
called it Authentic Identity,
so it was more using
the language like this,
and so the show itself was this bridge
between African-American
culture and Africa,
and finding a way of
bridging those positions,
and so the collection really
was a real clarity on that,
so my show that I'm
doing here in London is,
I'd say, an expansion of that.
Now we're kind of in the
sort of, like I said,
the sort of post-George Floyd time.
I thought it'd be great to
sort of celebrate Black culture
in this country over the last 50 years.
And it's interesting, there's
a company out of Nigeria,
funny enough, a fintech business
which is home-grown out of Nigeria,
but it's a platform that enables farmers,
they have like nine million
farmers on their platform,
helping them with the
agriculture business,
and they've actually came
in and effectively supported
and sponsored this
event that I'm creating.
And for me, that's quite
special, 'cause historically,
I would never have thought
that an African tech business,
home-grown, could be in
that position to do that.
They're about to list on
the New York Stock Exchange.
So the whole thing,
behind the scenes through
to the designs is funded and
the design has that link.
It has that link, but more importantly,
it's a very important
point, because in the,
in this shifting change of time,
it's about having a voice, right?
And a voice as a designer,
a voice in the tech world,
there's all this big debate
about, do you have enough women,
do you have enough representation
on your board - Black representation,
all this has been a very
loud shout for the last,
let's say, 12 months, right?
And what's beautiful
and I feel quite happy about
is that the traditional rule
of it is, I would have to go elsewhere
to get the support, right?
And it's great that
it's coming from Africa
to actually support something
here, that's really important.
'Cause it's very easy to lose
track of one, the influence,
and the creative influence
of the culture here,
because what makes
actually London special,
I can say London 'cause I'm a Londoner,
is it's the melting pot
of lots of cultures.
And sort of being able to respect
and receive that I think
is London's future,
and so I feel that this show
will be a very good example,
a catalyst for that realization,
because it's not about
hitting you over the head
with this is who I am,
I'm Black and I'm proud,
it's not about that.
It's more about, this is who I am,
and it's great, and I'm happy
to be here and contribute.
Yeah, so that's really
what the show's about.
I wanna get into some of your designs
and how you come to those,
but I think what's fascinating
with the pandemic is
fashion will have changed.
I mean, it's always changing,
but perhaps this is one of those moments
where we don't go back
potentially, especially men,
to suits, and we were already
moving away from them,
but now, if you've just
been on a Zoom call--
Look, look,
I think it's just been a
very interesting time, right?
I think so much has
happened in these two years.
Technology, Zooms, George
Floyd, I mean it's a lot, right?
For me as a creative, all of
those things have influenced
and touched me, and I
think it's just great
that we can start to see people again,
I could do this with you, right?
And so in terms of what I'm
gonna do with the collection,
there's a strong cultural
African culture aspect
that is probably more visible
in my work now than it
has been previously,
and a real celebration of that,
not that I never did it before,
but I feel the time, what
we're in today allows
and more importantly, I think
it's important to demonstrate.
I still have the traditional values
of my Savile Row background
'cause I love that,
I love the tailoring of that,
and so you see that very
distinctly in the collection,
but also there's an embrace
of this casual wear,
because no one's had to
wear a suit for two years.
I think it's quite sad
that we'd seen the decline
of the suit already,
and now perhaps it's maybe gone even more.
We've seen in suit sales
and all of that, it's down.
It's really down, yeah,
I mean COVID definitely
kind of compounded that,
and I think prior to that,
there was just birth of
sort of like casual wear
in a way that it was moving into our,
even our work lines in a significant way,
but where I position myself,
tailoring was never a uniform in my world.
Tailoring was a choice.
So people would come to me for
special occasions, weddings,
award ceremonies,
and so the dynamic
around how I work is more
about pleasing the, finding
the ingredient for the wearer
for whatever the occasion
that you need the suit for,
so it's slightly different.
It is, but I suppose I'm
just asking maybe as well
for your view on whether,
you know, that moment,
I don't know the exact moment,
but people stopped wearing hats.
When we, I wonder if you
think the pandemic is one
of those moments, not
necessarily just with the suit,
but kind of where we get even
less formal in some ways,
in the way that we dress.
Yeah, yeah, I think, no,
I think for sure,
the pandemic's made us all
not maybe paid the same amount
of attention 'cause you're at home, right?
And you're doing Zoom calls.
But in the same breath,
now it's starting to shift.
We all wanna go out, and
now we're starting to think
about what we're wearing,
so that's changed.
What's interesting is is
the purchase on the, online,
on eComm, 'cause apparently
there was a lot of purchases,
but very particular type of
purchases online and then--
Elasticated trousers, if you're
a woman, bigger knickers.
Exactly, exactly, exactly,
so that's quite interesting,
and there's no question that
eComm universe as a consequence
of the pandemic has really
shaped the business,
and for sure, I've had to react to that.
I think that's interesting as well,
because during lockdown,
did you have to do consultations remotely,
and how did you find moving
the business in that way
and trying to make those connections?
Can you do it?
It was very unusual actually,
and I tried a few consultations on Zoom,
which I did personally, and
that was quite interesting.
I ended up cracking a lot more jokes.
I was more funny on Zoom.
Because the whole thing
seemed so crazy to me,
because you're trying to work out,
oh could you step further back
from the screen, and it's,
you're talking to a CEO,
Tilt your head this way.
you're talking like CEOs
run like $120 billion,
could you move, could you turn around?
I think there is a way to do it.
I need more time to figure it out.
Well, and the advances in technology,
the idea that you don't need
to measure in person by hand,
it can be done by machines,
what do you make of all of that?
I think we're still, I think
it's, the tech's out there,
I just, I haven't personally
been able to experience it.
I mean the, ultimately,
the best way we'd do it is if
there's some way you're able
to use that facial
recognition tech on the body.
I'm actually of the view
that the future would be,
that everything is made to measure,
and somehow,
Really?
there is a manufacturing unit that,
in the way that you're at home
and then you have a request of something,
and it's made for you at the
factory and then sent to you.
I know, I feel that it's
possible in the future
for that to happen.
Because it's kind of mad
that it couldn't, right?
That all of it is such an estimate,
the idea that one size
of a type of a size
could fit so many people.
Exactly.
But it's not just that, because the nature
of the business is that
I don't know who's going
to purchase it, so if I don't know,
I have to make 20 variables
of size to fit you, see?
And so what happens is it's
designed to create waste.
So if you know the measures,
then you don't have to make the five sizes
to find you.
So that could be the route
to a greener future, but I
mean big fashion, fashion,
'cause the hugest houses of this,
and I'm not talking the couture
end, I'm talking the faster
end, they still just don't work
on any way of that level, do they?
The amounts of waste is huge.
This is a massive issue.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, there's a,
no, there's, absolutely,
and, but the thing is it's
also a challenge for them,
so, unless you're controlling
your manufacturing,
which a lot of them don't.
They may have really good
agreements with manufacturers,
it's a very difficult
one to change outside
of creating a system where
you can bring the garment
that you're no longer working back
where it could be recycled.
I don't see how they're
gonna resolve that issue.
How many suits do you have?
Good question.
I recycle.
So interesting enough,
I only have as much as
I need in a given time,
so maybe, it's maybe 20,
maybe 20?
Is that it?
Yeah, I wear it and I'll sell it off.
And I asked that because I'm trying
to think about what you
said about confidence
and what a suit can do.
So do you really feel in yourself
when you put on your suit,
what do you feel?
How does it change you?
Well for me, it's interesting
'cause I've been wearing
suits since I was like 16,
so I have a wholly different
light, it's like putting on,
it's almost like putting on
a tracksuit I would imagine,
for me, right?
So I don't, I'm not thinking about it.
But if it's something, I
think, there's two things.
One is the suits and
having a suit made for you,
and then my intention when I create a suit
for an individual.
So my intention is always to
encourage the wearer
to be who they are, be in
their truth effectively,
and so, and I like to support that
in the way I cut the suits,
and so once they look at themselves
and they're feeling
better about who they are,
they show more of who they are.
Suits and clothes are our
armor a lot of the time.
They say how we feel
about ourselves a lot.
I volunteer with a charity,
a women's charity called Smart Works
where we dress women who are
going for job interviews,
and obviously we're not tailoring it,
it's largely donated clothes,
but when you dress a woman,
when you dress someone,
you help them get dressed,
as an adult so not as a child,
the feeling it gives them,
that effort's gone into their
appearance, is extraordinary.
Yes, absolutely, and
it's a very good point.
When I'm dressing a client
and he's putting the suit on
for the first time after we've
done the fitting process,
the dressing of that individual,
the experience of putting
the jacket, putting,
helping them put the trouser
on is quite a powerful,
powerful relationship
actually, 'cause effectively,
they undress in front of you,
and then they dress in front of you,
and then that experience
when they look at themselves
in the mirror is quite
something, it's quite special.
Are you on social media?
I'm trying.
My daughter says I'm hopeless.
I'm really trying.
I'm still on the fringes of social media.
I think you should stay there.
You know?
I'm sort of, I understand it's,
I need to be more engaged,
but it's interesting
because I think on one hand,
it's fantastic
because then you get a
chance to really express
and there's no, in a way, middle
man to your communication.
Also in the same breath,
anyone could say anything they want.
Truth or not, they can just say,
this is an issue.
Well also,
there's no gatekeepers
in quite the same way.
If you start a business now,
certainly in the fashion world,
you can just get people to
wear your stuff, influencers,
and then it grows.
You don't have to have bricks and mortar
on Savile Row anymore.
No, no, no, exactly,
and which is, I have to say,
I'm really getting to understand,
because the main thing for
me is the real kind of,
it's always about
connecting with the wearer,
and I always go back to it.
I'm very spiritual about my work.
And so I like that dynamic
within every purchase,
even if they're not even aware
that that's what's happening,
once they put it on
and they've started feeling
good about themselves.
'Cause I've now been at it long
enough to be able to say it,
'cause probably historically I
wouldn't actually communicate
in that way, I'd say, oh you know,
they enjoy wearing my clothes,
but it's been a long enough time,
I know that's what it does, right?
And so that for me is
the most important thing,
and how do you communicate that
on social media is interesting.
And the fashion world sometimes
doesn't have the best
reputation, divas and the like,
and the best behaviors
and the work behaviors.
Well I have to say though,
I have to say, in the old days of fashion,
you had a lot of that, actually.
Lot of egos, huge amount of egos.
But I'd say probably in
the last five, eight years,
it's really changed a lot.
I remember going to fashion
awards and, of recent,
and everyone going up on stage
and the speeches were
a lot more considered,
not so much about what they've achieved
or who they are or who
they said they were,
there seems to be a big shift,
and it was needed, because--
How bad was it before?
At some points it was a
bit, just ridiculous, yeah.
There's a theater
requirement within fashion,
because you're a creative.
You're an artist.
So you're entitled to
wanna have purple roses
or whatever it is,
because this is the vision
that inspires you to create.
But sometimes the performances
went so beyond the realms
of reality
that they need to,
What's your,
pruning,
they needed to ground it,
yeah.
come back.
They need to be, yeah, step back.
What's your most diva-ish
request, you think?
That's quite funny, actually.
Go on.
What have you always gotta have?
Well no, no, actually me, I'm,
actually I think I'm quite,
I'm very clear about what I want,
I'm very detail-oriented
when it comes to my creative,
but probably my only major diva moment
I would say actually
is when I was a creative
director at Givenchy.
I was in the office design room,
and I wasn't getting things
done in the time that I wanted,
and I couldn't understand.
I was very diplomatic,
and so I went for lunch
with a friend of mine, and then
I was saying that, probably,
it's not moving quick enough.
And he said, "Yeah, but
they're French, you know,
"you gotta throw a tantrum."
I said, "What do you mean?"
"Gotta throw a tantrum?"
He said, "Yeah, you gotta go in there
"and you gotta tell 'em what you want,"
so I go in, I threw a tantrum,
and I got the stuff done immediately.
What does that look like,
you throwing a tantrum?
Well I was, I mean it was quite funny
because it was slightly performance.
I wanted black tulips.
It's a whole thing, black tulips,
I want black tulips
everywhere for the stage,
it was a whole thing,
so.
I want my black tulips
and I want them now.
Basically.
Who's the best person you've dressed?
Are you allowed to say?
Or a memorable moment for you,
with all these stories
and all these people?
I mean there's so many,
I mean there's story of Daniel Day-Lewis,
dressing him for the BAFTAs,
when he won for "Gangs of
New York," I think, yeah,
and he came to see me
first and I dressed him up
and that was really
beautiful, 'cause he gets,
he went on stage and he
won the award, he was,
he talked about his tailor
but he didn't know how to
say it, because it was,
because the thing is is when
you have that special moment,
there's a lot of pressure, right?
And so you, well at least it's what I do,
I like to make that moment when
I come to dress you a moment
where you don't feel that, so
it takes a lot of that away,
and then when I dressed Jamie Foxx,
when he won his Oscar for
"Ray," so that was great.
Incredible movie.
Yeah, great movie, and I've
become very good friends
with Jamie, and so that was special.
I would say there's been
many special moments.
And is it special, of course they win
and then you see them,
and they look sharp,
they look how you've talked about,
but is it the actual
connection that's made
that's the--
Yeah, that's, for me,
what's more important is how they feel.
Many, probably I'd say, most of the time
that I've dressed people,
the usual rule is,
they're going on a carpet
and you'd say, look,
make sure you tell them
that I dressed you or,
and I've always been kind
of the opposite to that.
I've always said, look, if
they said oh I'll mention,
I say look, don't worry about that.
If you're feeling good, it will be good.
Thank you so much.
And thank you so much for being with us.
Until we meet again, do
stay safe, and goodbye.